what's that belief nation that's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than you believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet and
so to help you on your journey today I'm
continuing my series on success advice
from the top how billionaires think all
you number two and as always as they're
watching if you hear something that
really resonates with you please leave
it down the comments below and put
quotes around it so other people can
enjoy and when you write it down it's
more likely to stick with yourself as
well enjoy
[Music]
I say to my girls
all of the time that your real work is
to figure out where your power base is
and to work on the alignment of your
personality your gifts that you have to
give with the real reason why you're
here that's that's a number one thing
you have to do is to work on yourself
and to fill your self up and keep your
cup full keep yourself full now I used
to be afraid of that I used to be afraid
particularly from people who say oh she
did she so Bella has them herself and
now I embrace it I considered a
compliment that I am full of myself
because you only when you're full I'm
full I'm overflowing my cup runneth over
I have so much I have so much to offer
and so much to give and I am not afraid
of honoring myself you know it's
miraculous when you think about it
sometimes being young and trying things
you're so naive and you don't know any
better
all you do is learn and if you fail it
doesn't matter and so whether I was 9 10
12 1621 the failures were irrelevant and
you know whether you're you know nine
twelve sixteen twenty one twenty two
twenty four you know I'm sleeping on the
couch you know I have a car with a hole
in the floorboard you know I'm living
like a bum and like a student and so
what did I have to lose and so I think
that influenced me as much as anything
so it you know my dad was like go for it
you know don't why not what do you got
to lose you know you have to sleep on a
different couch so I think that that was
motivation
I almost fashion believes that I can
only should expect to make money and
things that I understand and when I say
understand I don't mean understanding
you know what the product does or
anything like that I mean understand
what the economics of the business are
likely to look at look like ten years
from now or 20 years ago I know in
general what the economics of say
Wrigley chewing gum will look like ten
years now the internet isn't going to
change the way people chew gum it isn't
going to change which come they chew you
know if you own the chewing gum market
in a big way and you've got double mint
spearmint and juicy fruit those brands
will be there any analysis I can't
pinpoint exactly what the numbers are
going to look like on Wrigley but I'm
not going to be way off if I try to look
forward on something like that that
evaluating that company is within what I
call my circle of competence I
understand what they do I understand the
economics of it I understand the
competitive aspects of the business so
figuring out the economic consequences
TV
I think there's I don't know 20 25
million cents a year sold the United
States I don't think there's one of them
made in the United States anymore
I mean it's a TV set manufacturer what a
wonderful business of everybody nobody
had a TV in 1950 there they're about 45
to 50 everybody has multiple sets now
nobody in the United States has made any
real money making the sense they're all
out of business
you know the Magna boxes the rca's all
of those companies radio was the
equivalent the 20 over 500 companies
making radios in 1920s again I don't
think there's a u.s. radio manufacturer
at the present time but coca-cola you
know was it 1884 and Jacobs pharmacy or
whatever and so comes up with something
a lot of copiers over the years but now
you've got a company that is selling
roughly 1.1 billion eight ounce servings
of its product not all cokes right and
some others daily throughout the world
honored 17 years later so understanding
the economic characteristics of the
business is different than predicting
the fact that an industry is going to do
wonderfully so I look at the internet
businesses or look at tech messes I see
this is a marvelous thing and I love to
play around on the computer and I
ordered my books from Amazon and all
kinds of things but I know who's going
to win unless I know is going to win I'm
not interested in investing I'll just
play around on the computer and defining
your circle of competence is the most
important aspect of investing it's not
how important how large your circle is
you don't have to be an expert on
everything but knowing where the
perimeter of that circle of what you
know on what you don't know is and stay
inside of it is all important Tom Watson
senior who started IBM said in his book
he said I know genius said but I'm smart
in spots I stay around those spots and
you know that is the key so if I
understand a few things and I stick in
that arena I'll do okay and if I don't
understand something but I don't excited
about it because my neighbors are
talking about the stocks are going up
everything they start fooling around
someplace else eventually I'll get
creamed and I should
a lot of times my insurance people are
not setting goals that will be something
that somebody who becomes rich or is
could do anything you've got to be
excited about working on that for ten
years so you got to have a big enough
coal and you know you attracted those
people and you retain them and you keep
them focused and then my experience you
don't go wrong you know maybe you don't
get it next year or maybe you fail
entirely and you discover something more
exciting dorkon with the same set of
people
do something you're very passionate
about and don't try to chase what is
kind of the hot passion of the day I
think we actually saw this I think you
see it all over the place in many
different contexts I think we saw it in
the internet world quite a bit where you
know it's sort of peak of the sort of
Internet of you know mania and say 1999
you found people who were you know very
passionate something they kind of left
that job and decided I'm going to you
know do something in the internet
because it's you know it was almost like
the you know the 18-49 Gold Rush in a
way I mean you find that people if you
go back and stay to the history of the
18-49 Gold Rush you find that you know
at that time everybody who was in within
the shouting distance of California was
you know they might have been a doctor
but they quit being a doctor and they
started panning for gold and that that
almost never works and even if it does
work you know according to some metric
financial success or whatever it might
be I suspect it leaves you ultimately
unsatisfied so you really need to be
very clear with yourself and I think one
of the best ways to do that is this
notion of projecting yourself forward to
age 80 looking back on your life
and trying to make sure you minimize the
number of regrets you have that works
for that works for career decisions it
works for family decisions you know do
want I have a 14 month old son and it's
very easy for me to if I think about
myself when I'm 80 I know I want to
watch that little guy grow up and so
it's I don't want to be 80 and think
shoot you know I missed that whole thing
and I don't have the kind of
relationship with my son that I wished I
had and so on and so on so if you think
about that
so I guess another thing that I would
recommend to people is that they always
take a long term point of view and I
think this is something about which
there's a lot of controversy
see you know there's a there's a you
know something a lot of people and I'm
just not one of them believe that you
should live for the now I think what you
do is you think about the the great
expanse of time ahead of you and try to
make sure that you're planning for that
in a way that's going to leave you
ultimately satisfied so this is just my
this is the way it works for me and I
mean this is everybody needs to find
that for themselves so there are a lot
of paths to satisfaction and you need to
find one that works works for you
I think if you if you believe in what
you're doing and you know many people
will tell you you know what why your
mistake and why it'll never work and you
know but if you really believe
passionate what you're doing just dis
then keep going you know keep pushing on
keep pushing on and until you either
succeed or at least you know you realize
that you know just it's just not going
to happen and and and and then if it if
you don't succeed pick yourself up and
and you know try again and and
ultimately you know if you you know if
you're that determined you will succeed
in life and and if you don't you'll have
a a lot of fun trying
first of all focus on it right I mean I
think like you basically get what you
spend your time doing right I mean I
want the company to build three products
this year and we're going to work on a
few others because people are interested
in them but those are the three things
that I'm spending my product time on
right on you get what you put into it if
you spend a third of your time trying to
make the people around you better
through getting better people mentoring
getting them to be better getting the
best people in your organization you're
known to more in factual roles and I
think over time not just a cruise and
you get a better organization
think things out for yourself come to
your own judgments then simply conform
to conventional ways of thinking
conventional ways of dressing
conventional ways of acting that a lot
of this a lot of things are based on
fashion even morality at times is based
on fashion it was once that you know
slavery was once not considered not to
be immoral and people are people are
shocked that the ancient Greeks had
slaves that we had slavery in this
country as recently as you know higher
than thirty hundred forty years ago so
there are more moral value have to
really go back to first principles and
think things out for yourself whether
they're scientific principles or moral
principles or business ideas or product
ideas you have to think things out of
yourself
you know there's there's one one
sentence that I try to describe
bridgewater by and it's meaningful work
and meaningful relationships I what I
want meaningful work and meaningful
relationships through radical truth and
radical transparency so meaningful work
means like we're in a mission together
we're excited about we do we want to do
it excellently that's meaningful work
meaningful relationships are these
relationships and where there's you know
like the honesty helps you you can argue
things through but you always know that
there's honesty and that there's mutual
caring for each other
radical truth means that knowing what is
true to be able to deal with reality
whether you like the reality or not but
to know what reality is
like do you have imagine if you had a
disease would you want to know that you
had that disease or would you want not
want to know I want to know and so to
know do you if you have a weakness do
you want to know you have the weakness
or do you not want to know radical truth
and radical transparency means you get
to see everything that's very powerful
from our perspective and I think it's
true for technology in particular you
know the world keeps changing as I said
earlier so in a big part of what I focus
on at any given time is you know making
sure we are innovating and building
products of the future you know it's
just got to be a normal course of how
you think and so you know we are
constantly thinking about what to do
next so you know Android is very popular
people are using smart phones but you
know I always didn't think about what is
the next version of how people use
computing right and so we are thinking
about you know things like virtual
reality or augmented reality so these
are all new areas that we are constantly
thinking about it and so you have to do
that on a constant basis to push forward
thank you guys so much for watching I
hope you enjoyed I'd love to know what
did you think of this video what was the
point that really stood out the most -
that really made you think that you're
going to immediately somehow apply to
your life or to your business please
leave it down comes below I'm really
curious to see what you have to say
thank you guys again so much for
watching I believe in you
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon